mock yeah in yeah Bird yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah Dumb and Dumber a that's a funny
movie this one
[Music]
isn't The Hunger Games Mocking J part
Uno this one takes place in
Mexico no he doesn't catniss everine or
as I like to call her cat piss everine
sure I'm the first one to come up with
that has returned right after the events
of Catching Fire she has like serious
PTSD no one seems to give a [__] that
she has it though what's cool about this
one is the film's really about the
revolution the rebels like taking charge
fighting back going against the man
white power and black power and it's led
by none other than Katniss and Katniss
everine I personally love like I love
her a lot like I've been trying to get
my girlfriend to get on board with
Katniss but she's like catness isn't
real that's not possible and I'm like
shut up you don't know what you're
talking about and then she says I'm in
denial I don't know what she's talking
about but catness she's complicated
she's vulnerable but at the same time
she's strong she's focused she's
ambitious she's what every woman should
be you hear that Veronica every woman
should be able to fire a bow and arrow
and save me cuz I'm Peta and I'm a
little [__] who can't take care of
himself and I love the role she plays in
this particular installment because yeah
she's the leader we all saw that coming
but coming but at this ah but coming but
but she's like really relatable you
definitely identify with her I mean it
helps that you saw two films with her
already but you really do feel like I I
I can kind of feel what it would be like
to be in this position and one day I
will be watch them the Ro's getting all
[__] up you're going to be like
where's Ryan Wright I'm going to be like
I don't want to be a part of it but I
still want you to want me to be a part
of it but I'm going to tell you I don't
want to be a part of it then eventually
I'm going to just shut up like a badass
and be like let's do this [__] they had
this interesting aspect where the
resistance wants to do like promotional
videos of the Rebellion that way they
can inspire all the districts to join
the Rebellion by the way something I
notic about The Hunger Games in all the
districts it seems that only blacks and
white people have survived I don't see a
single Asian or Mexican guy in these
groups it's all blacks and whites what
the [__] happened to the rest of the
race and have you mentioned this guy
whether or not of his passing but Philip
Seymour Hoffman Philip Seymour Hoffman
that's my impression of Philip Seymour
Hoffman it's like tired Bane I'm Phillip
Seymour Hoffman catniss you're the
leader of the Rebellion but no seriously
he's fantastic in this film there's more
to him in this film than in the last one
he does he gets a lot more life to him a
lot more colors a lot more of the
palette a lot more you know different
strings of you know what I'm talking
about metaphors about how there's like a
lot of [__] going on in him the writing
and direction of this film it's good
it's solid as the other two I would say
everything about this film is for the
most part pretty good but this is a
review so I feel like I should point out
a couple of things that I wasn't on
board with for
starters Gail played by Chris
Hemsworth's brother that's what it'll
forever be known as Who the hell's going
to call him Liam come on but no I like
Liam Hemsworth I I do I I genuinely
enjoy looking at him he's not bad to
look at okay he's one of those like
dashing human beings where you're just
like holy [__] how did you get so
blessed [__] you Liam Hemsworth I never
read the books but I feel like Gail
could be like a mysterious badass
supporting character but instead he's
kind of just moping around the whole
time like he always looks so damn
depressed it's so obvious that he's he's
just a little whiny [__] in some
moments like all he does is body
language that tells you I want cat
inness but I don't know catness wants me
I'm Philip seor Hof dude grow some balls
and say something for a change he says
this one line you only notice me when
I'm depressed I'm like well dude you're
always [__] depressed so get the [__]
over it I just want him to like fight
for something or like get emotional
about [__] instead of being some guy
who's kind of boring and then he's only
cool whenever he's like firing an arrow
and I feel like pointing it out because
this guy is in it more than pea is but I
did like what they did with pea I mean I
personally feel that catniss puts a
little too much attention on Peta cuz
peta's always like oh I'm about to die
oh I'm in trouble again I'm in danger
and cace is like Peta P you notice when
Jennifer Lawrence cries her whole face
just he's always [__] crying about
Peta for some reason now he's not in
this movie a lot you mainly see him
through the capital TV where he is
pretty much on the side of the capital
and the rebels are like [__] you Peter
bread you were on our side but you're
like is pedo really on their side is he
being forced to say these things and it
made him more compelling to watch than
the other two films and there's no game
in this one it's strictly about the
Revolution and I loved a lot about what
they did with it you know it's more than
just a dark movie like it's pretty
haunting it's really menacing and it's
pretty damn violent like there's moments
of genocide in it what I like about it
is like you really do want the rebels to
win however though I did find this film
to be a little too melodramatic I felt
like a lot of the drama was kind of
strung out like at times it kind of made
me a little bored like I saw two other
movies already that pretty much have
established how horrible the world is
and this film was like doing reminders
throughout the whole thing of like
remember how [__] up everything is
right now yeah it's still pretty [__]
up like I know can we just stick to the
adventure a little bit and not having a
hunger game for this movie that's okay
cuz it's not necessary to tell this
story but at the same time it does still
happen to work against the film part one
and two the best parts are the Hunger
Game sequences they're exhilarating
action-packed they're suspenseful
there's a time frame so it makes it that
much more intense it's very personal so
you you know you only one can survive so
it's heartbreaking from the beginning of
it all now when you take all that away
even though there's still a lot at stake
even more than before for some reason
because it doesn't feel as personal and
it takes away a lot of the fun out of
the movie it's not as exhilarating as
the first two were and only reason I'm
bringing that up is because a lot of the
emotion you might have felt during part
one and two you might not get a similar
generation of emotions from that oh
catniss I have boobies boobies for
Katniss
do you want me to be pretend to be
catniss for a night baby shut up you
know you want me to shut up I respected
that the story really takes you into the
slumps of this world because you get
some of it in the first one you get some
of it in the second one but this one's
like no you're going to spend your time
in a pile of [__] like [__] La that
godam like that place used to be so
pretty I like a good Revolution story
like The Matrix Revolutions everyone can
get on board for that every single
person thought the Matrix Revolutions
was the best one of all of them quote me
on that and if you think I'm joking huh
no I'm not you [__] [__] you get it
baby cuz no one really liked no one
really liked the third one but anyway
yeah a lot of stories that end with a
revolutionary tale especially if it's a
sequel they tend to not be as powerful
for some reason AKA Matrix Revolutions
AKA Return of the
Jedi it's the only one I could really
think of Return of the King was pretty
damn good like don't get me wrong I
really did like this film but compared
to the first two it's number three out
of the three of them wait that's going
to confus it's the the weakest one out
of the three of them but it's not a weak
movie it has the least strength out of
the three have I made myself clear
trying to prevent a lot of hatred which
I know I'm already going to get cuz some
of you guys just don't like me and keep
watching the [__] videos for some
reason I can totally see why there's
mixed opinions on this because a lot of
things I talked about but still there's
solid acting there's solid writing solid
directing the production design and
music are still great everything about
it is still wonderful it's just not as
strong as the first two let me get
straight to the point here all in all I
got to say The Hunger Games Mocking Jay
part one has the longest title and got
it it
right all right guys thanks for checking
out my review for The Hunger Games
Mocking J part one why don't you go
ahead scroll to that comment box below
and tell me are you a team Gail or team
Peta tell me but don't ruin the [__]
ending for me and last but not least if
you want to get updated every time one
of my reviews or videos is out go ahead
and click on this button by my d to
subscribe that's right the
dick let me tell you something about
this little mocking
jay every time he's about
to make a lady
whistle he always uses three
fingers and boy do they
whistle
[Music]
punch
that I just realized I did the X Files
tune and not the Hunger Games tune